cette technocratie et suivi ce par
rapport à la recette internationale
standard ils ont le la technocratie
gaulliste ou la technocratie delà de la
reconstruction qui a suivi la libération
elle était indépendante
il y avait des têtes fortes têtes qui
réfléchissait avec l'idée d'ailleurs de
définir des modèles originaux
le nous sommes passés sur la défensive
et notre technocratie au tout premier
chef aux vaches et parlent anglais si je
puis dire
et elle parle européen est le même et
vous êtes leur part sont propres à sa
part et un an elle croit à ce qu'elle a
pris elle est ce qu'elle a appris à
l'école et l'école relais effectivement
une semaine vulgate international qui
est supposé porter les bonnes recettes
etc en plus quand on est un imitateur on
n'est jamais aussi bon que l'original
donc elle est faible dans l'imitation et
le suivisme ce qui ajoute encore une
difficulté supplémentaire là on est au
coeur du malheur français c'est à dire
la perte d'initiative de capacité à se
dire le monde est comme il est on va
définir notre voix à nous là dedans
[Musique]